I have a super ironic story for you here
Republican presidential nominee Donald
Trump yesterday went on CNBC and he said
the Federal Reserve is doing exactly
what President Obama wants by keeping
interest rates low Fed chair Janet
Yellen and the central bank are
political they are working with
President Obama in conjunction with him
in order to keep rates low to keep the
stock market prices artificially high to
make it seem as though the economy under
President Obama is stronger than it is
Trump actually said that Janet Yellen
should be ashamed of what she's doing to
the country saying that they are not
nearly independent this is the
know-nothing right wing knee-jerk
reaction if the stock market does well
under a Democrat it's because rates have
been artificially deflated in order to
pump up stock market prices so big
picture generally speaking with many
economic indicators we see rates and
prices move in opposite directions the
conventional wisdom is for example when
mortgage rates go down the values of
home prices go up when mortgage rates
start going up the sales price of homes
will come down or at least not grow as
quickly sort of this opposite motion now
which causes which well good luck
figuring that out in the stock market
similar idea stock market high typically
you have low federal funds rate which is
the rate at which banks can borrow money
from each from the federal government
the overnight rate as it's colloquially
called
Trump says the rates are artificially
low to boost President Obama's legacy
there are a few different things to
think about here number one think about
the scenario that Republicans are
espousing here
President Obama is controlling the Fed
to keep interest rates low to make
himself look better president obama is
controlling the Congressional Budget
Office so they will lie about the
decrease to the national deficit such
that President Obama will look better
the Bureau of Labor Statistics President
Obama is controlling that so that they
will lie about the number
of jobs created and the unemployment
rate to make President Obama look better
very quickly you can see that it's
absolutely ridiculous and it makes no
sense at all but the other point is this
whole concept of artificially low rates
how would we be able to tell if a rate
is lower than it should be at its
equilibrium point
well when rates are artificially or
unnaturally low you see inflation really
accelerate and we're just not seeing
that an economist Paul Krugman has
written a written about this many times
I've read a number of other articles by
economists about this issue there is no
indication right now that rates are
truly artificially low they are
historically very low but artificially
implies something very very different so
it's funny when I hear Donald Trump say
someone else is incompetent wait a
second you're the guy who can't go more
than two talking points deep on any
issue other than maybe the minimum wage
and the reason you can go more than two
talking points deep is because you take
six different positions on it really the
the pot calling the kettle black
somebody who lives in a glass house
throwing stones whatever analogy you you
want it's becoming laughable and very
very dangerous at this point because
this is the guy who might be the next
president